if you think about the scale it's quite
quite interesting 30% of all the
greenhouse gases that we've ever emitted
have been absorbed by the oceans but
they're getting saturated they just
can't absorb as much as they used to
absorb and we think within a matter of
decades they'll stop being able to
absorb more which doesn't mean the heat
will dissipate it means the oceans won't
be able to regulate as much of the
atmosphere and the atmospheric trends
will get worse and more pronounced so
what are the countermeasures if you like
the solutions that should be taken to
deal with this well there's a different
series that you'd want to deal with both
to minimize emissions and then to manage
effects on the emissions side ultimately
it has to be a climate change agreement
we have to move forward with the
commitments we made in Paris and the
next round of commitments after that and
reduce the greenhouse gases that are
leading to these changes carbon dioxide
which is absorbed by oceans and leads to
acidification isn't going to be stopped
by an effort to manage the oceans
themselves
you have to manager the source and at
the other end you have to manage the
impacts and the impacts come from
damages to coral reefs they come from
movement of fish species they come from
sea level rise all of those require a
host of strategies that are different
from those to minimize emissions and
what about the polar ice cap because as
you know there's a lot of argument about
this some people say well the ice cap
historically has come and gone it melts
in the summer it comes back in the
winter are you particularly concerned
about that I'm deeply concerned about it
now we should distinguish a little bit
between the northern ice cap which is
largely floating on top of the oceans
and the consequences of its melting
which is really gonna make the oceans
fresher that saltwater is diluted by all
the fresh water that's in the ice one of
the things we think will happen there is
it could stop this large-scale ocean
circulation patterns the salt water is
critical as that if it becomes fresh
water it doesn't behave the same way and
on the Antarctic side we end up with
land-based sources and melting of those
ice caps is going to lead to an enormous
sea level rise so we have problems on
both poles and they're the
more and more severe and if you look at
this conference the third our oceans
conference called by the secretary of
state in America what what has changed
what has come out of this conference
that might actually deal with these
problems I think a number of different
things we're coming out of the
conference the first is just an
elevation and a recognition of the
seriousness of the problem the second a
whole host of pledges made around a
variety of actions that people can take
mostly focus on the ocean side so
they're looking at mitigation minimizing
risk and damage we're setting aside
enormous areas as reserves for species
that they can actually continue to be
sustained we're looking at some no
fishing zones we're also looking at
coastal protections one of the problems
we have with oceans is not just climate
but all these land-based sources of
pollution managing those an enormous
benefit and finally I think we'll see
later this afternoon in a panel that'll
be held at the near the end of the
session explicitly focused on climate an
elevation of the importance of working
on the Paris agreement and getting
countries to reduce their emissions
which are creating part of these
problems